[Musique]
voici l'histoire d'une grande famille
unie depuis des siècles qui travaillent
main dans la main pour valoriser un
paysage c'est vraiment toutes ces
générations de forrest et qui se sont
succédé la qui ont travaillé sur ces
arbres et qui pour obtenir des sujets
aussi beau star bri les magnifiques au
service d'une industrie qui transforme
cette ressource en barriques grâce à un
savoir faire unique qu'il faut préserver
est ce que c'est un métier qui est un
vieux métiers puis on fait pas assez
publicité sur ce métier là pourtant
c'est un métier magnifique car le bois
de chêne et la touche française qui
permet aux grands vins du pays d'être
mondialement reconnu moi j'ai accepté de
payer mais barry plus cher pour avoir
une précision une une finesse de grain à
séchage naturel
exactement adapté et comme je le voulais
delarbre automnaux bienvenue dans un
monde où l'on prend son temps
les apparences sont parfois trompeuses
si vous vous promenez dans les forêts
françaises vous aurez le sentiment
d'être dans une forêt naturelle si le
milieu l'est le paysage lui a été
modelée par l'homme nous sommes en forêt
domaniale de blois dans le loir et cher
nous sommes dans un peuplement qui a été
façonné par l'homme un peuplement qu'il
ya 110 ans si on regarde un petit peu
autour de nous tous les chaînes sont à
peu près de la même grosseur ils ont à
quelques années près le même âge
depuis des siècles l'homme a utilisé la
forêt avant tout comme bois de chauffage
ses habitudes ont fini par ruiner la
forêt française et ce n'est qu'au début
du 19e siècle qui a éclos une prise de
conscience sur la nécessité d'avoir une
véritable gestion forestière c'est ce
que l'on appelle la sylviculture tous
les dix ans le forestier va intervenir
dans le peuplement et va enlever
quelques tiges au profit de ces arbres
objectif l'idée c'est de produire une
forêt de la meilleure qualité que l'on
puisse faire on a l'exemple ici d'un
chêne qui a un trait rouge est ce cet
arbre là va certainement être abattus
l'hiver prochain
et
l'esprit c'est d'aider ses congénères
autour de lui qui sont de meilleure
qualité les arbres auto au tour vont
avoir un petit peu plus d'eau plus d'air
pour mieux évoluer
dans les forêts de la région centre val
de loire le chêne et le roi un roi qui
est chouchouté à toutes les étapes de sa
vie pourtant la sélection est dur seuls
les plus forts traverseront les âges et
vivront jusqu'à 200 en attirant tous les
regards grâce à une caractéristique
précise ce qu'on appelle le graphe à un
arbre à grain fin c'est un arbre qui a
des cernes d'accroissement très fin donc
on cherche la finesse et la régularité
est donc
particulièrement en région centre on a
des arbres qui poussent très lentement
parce qu'on a une sécheresse l'été et
que ça empêche les arbres de pousser
trop vite et alors il est recherché en
tonnellerie parce qu'il apporte des
arômes différents
par rapport à des accroissements peu
plus large
le chêne à grain fin une ressource
convoitée qui est soumis un subtil
équilibre entre régénération via les
semis la csu perdants on voit bien d'où
ils ont démarré un tacle à la première
pousse tac et la deuxième puis
l'abattage des arbres matures proposer
aux plus offrants
[Musique]
acheter du bois en france rien de plus
simple vous avez 45 secondes et une
seule chance pour proposer la meilleure
offre afin d'obtenir une parcelle cette
entreprise de tonnellerie a un besoin
vital d'acquérir du bois de qualité
le 3 le deuxième état sera le troisième
est à 55 milles
de peu mais c est cette vente de bois
français est ouverte aux acheteurs du
monde entier
sa de fortes chances de partir en chine
encore ses poils longs tirés débit de
qualité et plo et meyrin et le reste
maintenant le gestionnaire ça par contre
ça vous de quel sentiment de voir
ces vies appartient la désolation prison
parce que c'est de la matière qui part
que les qui fait le travail et personne
donc c'est de la matière brute qui
parlent
les portes les portes sont grandes
ouvertes
pas d'achat cette fois ci mais
l'entreprise familiale a de quoi faire
pour les prochains mois
[Musique]
cette parcelle 33 en forêt de blois
c'est un peu le jackpot pour
l'entreprise grillé
[Musique]
acheter cent seize mille euros elle a le
droit d'exploiter les 95 chaîne ciblés
par le nfd chaîne qui ont 200 ans et qui
doivent faire place aux nouveaux
arrivants est ici dans le coffre-fort de
la forêt française on y trouve le nec
plus ultra
[Musique]
on est sur une forêt de haute futaie
c'est à dire des étrons très haut avec
des grains et des couleurs assez
fantastique donc c'est des bois qui sont
très coté est très recherchée par les
tonneliers avec un prix d'achat de plus
de 1000 euros par chaîne stéphane
cherche un bois parfait sans défaut pour
produire les merrains qui serviront à
façonner les tonneaux elle a déjà on est
sur une jolie couleur avec des jolies
grain donc qui va nous qui - destinés
pour des grands vins donc la rectitude
du bois on a on est on a le fil du bois
pour qui convient très bien pour la
tonnellerie et je pense que c'est un
bois d'accidentalité qui est assez long
donc qui nous convient très bien pour
l'atelier le risque que ce bois la
direction d'apple à abbey landry
la merranderie c'est l'atelier de
découpe ici ne parlait plus de chaînes
mais de meyrin la matière première de la
tonnellerie et pas question pour le
gérant de tailler un produit aussi cher
n'importe comment
on recherche en premier lieu c'est le
fil du bois c'est à dire que l'on soit
toujours dans le dans ce film là un brin
file droit et exemple des exemples
défaut donc la voyez on va faire une des
courses comme ça
on a des petits pictos donc là ça va
être partenaires attendent à partir avec
la découpe
[Musique]
faut pas prendre trop été pour pas
prendre trop fin pour qu'ils puissent
réaliser les deux duels de lens pourquoi
que trop de pertes on est déjà on est
déjà sur 80% de faire quand on fait 20
25 % de rendement sur une grenade une
belle brune à meyrin et c'était déjà
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mélina tout très cher on est sur un
colis produits et donc voilà là on
enlève beaucoup beaucoup de matière et
après cher le minimatic concerts
et voici ce qu'il en reste un arbre de
30 mètres de haut des planches fine
identique qu'on appelle des duels seuls
les plus belles et sans défaut vont
servir à la fabrication des fûts mais
pas avant trois ans
on parle de maturation donc il faut que
les les bois soie lavée par la pluie est
séché par le soleil et dans un cycle à
peu près de 24 à 36 mois pour bien laver
l'état n'a pas plu 9h à voir ce coup de
deux sèvres au moment des dégustations
de fruits
c'est l'histoire de la vie le cycle
éternel bref vous connaissez la chanson
à la tonnellerie l'arbre retrouvent une
seconde vie après un montage en rose
composée d'une trentaine de douelle le
tonneau rentrer en contact avec le feu
après le montage en rose on va passer à
l'étape du fermage c'est à dire que
c'est un flic foot fermé à la bonne
température
un futur est trop chaud ou va être
cassant un flux qui va être trop froid
deux cas sont aussi là on est vraiment
la bonne température pour pas le fermer
c'est quoi la bonne température c'est
entre 40 et 50 degrés à l'extérieur
qu'il faut compter en moyenne en général
c'est ça par rapport au temps
l'extérieur faut compter ça vaut près
pour qu'il soit que le bois soit bien
souple propos reprendre sa forme ses
fûts sont destinés aux plus grands vins
leur fabrication exige donc une maîtrise
parfaite par exemple chauffer la
barrique de l'intérieur sans la brûler
c'est le blues in âge et ça reste le
moment le plus délicat
quand on va chauffer différentes
températures qu'on m'a donnée au fus mes
différentes 0 pour sortir on va passer
par l'avaline voit passer par là mende
par le réglisse et la caféine à ces
différents arômes qui vont ressortir
plus on va chauffer plus c'est différent
cerveau ressortir et c'est le client qui
vous dit je veux tu es la rom ne furent
par rapport à ce qu'il va mettre à
l'intérieur par aman et vinifié quand il
va faire sa transformation je sais ce
qu'il est exactement comme vin ce qu'il
veut comme chauffe et par rapport à ça
je vais faire la chauffe approprié
une fabrication artisanale qui permet
des créations sur mesure
les fûts de chêne de la région centre
sont prisés par les vignerons les plus
exigeants de la planète et bien sûr par
les grands châteaux bordelais
[Musique]
entre les forêts du val de loire et la
gironde c'est un mariage heureux
fidèle et à succès qui dure depuis plus
de 30 ans la rencontre a eu lieu lorsque
des pionniers du vin se sont intéressé
davantage alors barriques traditionnels
monde d'avant était beaucoup plus
empirique c'est à dire du temps de nos
parents grands parents la barrique
exister la barrique elle a fait des
centaines d'années qui a des barriques
des vieux les anciens plutôt que les
vieux les anciens savait que la barrique
était un élément constitutif donne au
vin mais c'était d'ailleurs plus
empirique qu'ils avaient essayé toutes
les essences le chêne aujourd'hui c'est
99% delà de la barrique mais toutes les
essences ont été essayées les formes les
tailles des barriques et on est arrivé
aujourd'hui à cette barrique de 225
litres en chaîne qui est le
l'allemagne le meilleur contenant qu'on
puisse trouver pour nos grands vins de
bordeaux si le mariage fonctionne aussi
bien c'est avant tout une question de
taille du grain la croissance lente du
chêne donne des grain très fin et permet
l équilibre entre les tanins du vin et
du bois mais à pomerol comme à lussac le
sol joue un rôle important
bonjour et bienvenue au château la rose
derrière nous sommes ici c'est la
commune de lussac saint-émilion à 10km
de saint-émilion
un vignoble de 14 hectares plantés sur
un terroir argilo calcaires donc le cas
caire va donner beaucoup de finesse
aux vins élargie elle va donner plutôt
sa structure donc on pourra produire des
vins qui sont aptes un long
vieillissement et notamment en barriques
ses vins d'exception sont élevées en
tonneaux peu de temps après les
vendanges
les merlots 2020 ici dans le chai à
barriques le vieillissement dure en
moyenne 14 mois et permet d'exprimer
toute la richesse du vin
moitié
métier dont convoité
on préfère vraiment commencé à
travailler sur le label aromatiques oui
les tannants s'assouplissent un peu
mieux de bouge oui ça bien joué son rôle
dans le les sensations que je suis jeune
l'idée c'est justement que ce soit un
équilibre con que le bois soit là sans
être là et que vraiment ça met en valeur
le fruit ça va donner de la longueur du
volume lui donner une certaine épaisseur
au vin donc c'est ce que l'on recherche
nous pour nos vins et de la garde de la
complexité
moins de 2 % des vins dans le monde sont
élevés en barriques et pourtant le
nombre de fûts de chêne neuf a doublé en
30 ans désormais 600 milles tonneau sont
produits en france chaque année et les
deux tiers sont destinés à l'étranger
[Musique]